hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
so i realized that it's july which means
that a lot of you have recently
graduated college
and it made me think of the time in my
own life when i graduated
and i kind of just had no idea how to
adult
exactly all throughout college and like
even when i was in high school
applying to college i feel like there
was just like so many resources and
pamphlets and stuff around me about how
to do
college there were like seminars and
things that kind of all explain like how
you get into college
and then what do you do when you're
there and how do you make the most of
your experience
and getting in these days is like such a
hard part of the process like it's
gotten
even more competitive over the last few
years so if you're applying to college
right now
i feel for you and once you get to
college however way you might get there
a lot of things are kind of set up for
you there's orientation events and
icebreakers and roommate finders
and then throughout the year they
provide like academic and career
counseling
and then they also show you like where's
the best place to eat on campus or
whatever
there's clubs and organizations that you
can join with like built-in
socialization
which makes it really easy to make
friends college is like a super nice
sleep away camp or something
except of course it costs about as much
as a private jet to attend
and as you get ready to head off to
college you probably heard a lot of like
this proverbial college wisdom
from just about everyone around you
they'll give you little tips and wax
poetic
like how college is gonna be so
different from anything you've ever
experienced in your life
you're not gonna be able to get away
with not studying in college
you better get ready for all the
constant all-nighters it's gonna be
different
in college just you wait but the really
crazy part is gonna be the
party scene and all of this adds up to
the point that like when you're going to
college
even if you're a little bit nervous you
just have so much information
and advice at your fingertips that you
kind of know what to expect
but then college comes to an end and it
feels like in contrast to all the advice
you got in going to college
you get not nearly as much advice and
wisdom
about life after college that crowd of
wisdom givers and well-wishers
basically goes silent and that's the
problem
because as difficult as college is for
some people what we really all need help
with
is what comes next everyone talks about
college in the same way
because everyone who's gone to college
knows more or less
what it's like it's one of the last real
shared experiences that people can hold
on to
before they scatter to the wind after
graduation
after graduation people do so many
different things with their life
some of your friends graduate and
immediately get married
and somehow buy a house within like a
year
others grow their hair long and live in
a van for 18 months
and everyone in between does something
slightly different
traveling fancy jobs finding themselves
settling down or none of the above so
you can't really make a pamphlet or like
a pre-written
wise quote for the wild variety of
post-college experiences
the closest we get to any proverbial
wisdom with all of that
are kind of like memes that your cousin
posts about like adulting on facebook
every once in a while
it's like people's experience very so
much that it's kind of impossible to
prescribe like general blanket advice
that works for everybody
so no one kind of bothers i suppose
that's understandable but sometimes it
does feel a little intentional
like what it feels like sometimes is
like okay bye
good luck with your life but there are
such intense things that happen
after college in fact nearly all the
difficulties we face
things like emotional stress financial
stress like
big moves and career in life and stuff
they all happen
after college so naturally one of the
biggest things that i've heard from
lots of people in their 20s including
myself is something called post
college disillusionment where college is
this like super magical moment and
everything's fun
and super challenging and you're just
like wow there's like so much that
the world and life has to offer that
after you graduate and you step
out into the real world it somehow feels
a little disappointing
but it doesn't have to be that way i
think that life after college
is without a doubt the best part of life
or at least it can be because life after
college can be
anything it also lasts something like 80
years and college lasts four
so it'd be smart to make the 80 as good
as the four
or better so what do you do after
college what happens
next and what are some mindsets that are
really helpful to have
as you move into the longest phase of
your life
well let's start with the positive it's
that you
get to design your own life there's a
day that happens after your graduation
ceremony
after all the events and requirements
and like meetings and stuff are over
after everyone has finished
congratulating you and
basically gone back to their lives where
you wake up in bed
and realize that you're totally on your
own
there's no one to really tell you what
to do no classes to go to no homework
no dining halls nothing
and you'll come to realize that there
are literally gonna be
hundreds of those days and you have to
ask yourself
what are you gonna do with them that's
one of the weirdly scary things about
post-college life it's the first time
we're given the opportunity to truly
design
and builder lives from the ground up and
it can
feel overwhelming but if you approach it
kind of slowly
and like systematically that freedom can
turn
into the best thing ever and you'll come
to really appreciate it like i think
it's a blessing
in disguise take my word for it i've
been adulting for a while
and it gets easier so let's take it step
by step
there's your work life and your personal
life both of which are
obviously important for different
reasons inside of those are things like
your mental and physical health and ways
to spend time
like hobbies and a social life you
likely actually already had some sort of
structure that worked for you in college
obviously it's gonna be changing a lot
now but think of the systems and
structures that you liked and really
helped you
and kind of build off of that because
you already have something you can work
off of
and that's going to give you like a bit
of stability and familiarity during this
time
so let's start with work maybe you work
full-time or maybe your freelance
but either way you get to decide how
much of your life
you want to spend on work so what do you
want your work life to look like
a strict 9-5 or are you more of a
12-hour day hustler that
wants work to be a bigger part of their
life do you want to invest
all of your energy into work or do just
enough to succeed
both options are totally valid of course
you just have to choose which one you
like
or if you prefer something in between
like you could log off at 5 pm
or invest a few more hours per day and
stay on longer to build your
foundational work skills
and this plays right into figuring out
your own personalized work-life balance
or in other words how do you want to
balance your work life from your
personal life
and i gotta say i know it's easy to like
go full throttle when you first start
work
but i really encourage you to pay
attention to your body and mind during
this time
when they feel out of sorts like
definitely take a break
we might not really know or like max
capacity yet
but we all know what it feels to be
overextended and overwhelmed
so take some pre-emptive steps like
check in with yourself
to make sure that you don't get there
the things you do
in both parts of your life will
influence how the other feels
so find out what works well for you
maybe it's a glass of water in the
morning a walk break in the middle of
the day
eating a healthy lunch or turning off
your email notifications after work
which is what i do ain't nobody getting
an email from me after five o'clock
it does take like actual work to manage
your own
energy and time so that you have plenty
of both
in and outside of work so just be
patient
in figuring out what works for you
remember though that
you get to decide what your balance
looks like so when it comes to personal
life
one such shift that you're probably
going to feel from college life is
maintaining a social life this might be
like the first time in your life
which i know it was for me where you
can't rely
on the built-in socialization systems
that existed in school
you used to be with people your age
around you all the time
whether that be like in class or like
you lived in the dorms or whatever
but now everyone's in a different job
and maybe
even in different cities and it's easy
to fall in a pattern of going to work
going home and going to work again with
like nothing in between
if you're super outgoing and social in
college
don't be surprised if you start to feel
a little lonely especially
as things start out but it's totally
possible to build an
entirely new network of friends after
college
and just like everything else in this
strange new life it's all
completely up to you i've actually found
that like post college
it's kind of easier to make friends
maybe it's because people in your same
age range or like easy to talk to
and like the superficial cliques and
like clubs and stuff that existed in
school kind of
start to melt away when you're an adult
and once you get the hang of it it
becomes
really easy to find common ground with
like people in kind of your age group
because you've experienced similar
things before and i think part of why it
becomes easier to make friends is like
everyone's just trying to make it work
like life's hard for everyone
and like no one cares anymore about
things like clicks and stuff
and you know if making friends take some
time that's okay too you don't need to
immediately find like your best friend
five ever right away
because i found that in adulthood like
connections and like how you meet
friends like becomes increasingly
web like as in i mean like one person
and then they introduce me to like
two other people and then it kind of
like spiders out from there
of course it won't be as easy to
actually find time to hang out because
of like work and like other life things
but
it is possible i think we all know
especially after this long quarantine
that in the age of the internet
geographic constraints are not a big
deal when it comes to maintaining
friendships
just give it a little effort schedule
your hangouts
and utilize your weekends when you can
you'll be glad you did so once you start
working on your baseline
and you start feeling like both your
work and personal life
is like starting to get kind of like a
good balance or like you're on your way
then you might start thinking about your
life in kind of more of a macro
sense and even though it might be scary
it's kind of a good time to start
thinking about what life you want to
live
and what kind of effort do you need to
put in to make that happen
and one of the most important things
i've learned after graduating from
college
is that you get out what you put in
there's a version of your life where
you're like you're pretty happy you have
a pretty stable job you enjoy your
normal life but you feel like you're not
quite as happy as you could be
and if you don't want a life like that
it's up to you to put in the effort
to make your life better the difference
between like your pre-adulting life
and now is that your 100 responsible for
how you want to use your energy in life
and all of the energy you put
into something is gonna be all the
energy you get
out of something if that makes sense
sure school
is also kind of like that though if you
put in more effort
you'll probably learn more and get
better grades but there isn't a syllabus
anymore
there aren't calendars and guides for
how exactly to spend your time
no one's gonna make decisions for you or
give you what you need unless you work
for it
so you have to figure out a lot on your
own now for a lot of you
i know this is gonna be like the first
time you're ever steering your ship
and i know it can be really scary and
daunting
but i assure you it gets better with
time just move towards the things that
mean something to you
or bring goodness to your life in some
way for example
start to think about like routines that
you want to build into your life
that will benefit you like focusing on
exercising
or your nutrition okay so i'm gonna make
an assumption here
about you all college probably took care
of like
food for you you might have had a meal
card and like a cafeteria and like
different dining hall that you could go
to at like 2 a.m
and as a result it's likely and totally
fine
if all you can make is like buttered
noodles and like garlic bread i'm also
sorry if that's the wrong assumption i'm
just making assumption here for the
video
but i have to say there are some serious
advantages that come with being able to
cook your own food
you're more in control than you've ever
been before like the health content and
like choosing what goes into your food
and like choosing what you want to eat
when you get to like
cook when you want and add the
ingredients that you want
like that's so powerful after i learned
how to cook for myself in earnest
and building the skills to do so i'm
pretty freaking happy with the food that
i can make now
i'm not trying to say i'm like a pro
level chef by any means
but for my imaginary restaurant where
the only customer is me
i think i know my audience pretty well
we're responsible for keeping ourselves
nourished and healthy so i encourage you
to find what works for you
this is your life and you can live how
you want to
so try investing and putting your effort
and energy into this
and reap the rewards you'll also at some
point have to start
thinking about like real type adulting
things but i mean like what even really
is
adulting i guess it's just like being
able to take charge and like owning up
to and like taking responsibility for
like your life stuff
you'll start seeing taxes taken out of
paychecks and you'll like learn what a
w-9 is and stuff like
that it's all like honestly i think it's
really boring
and like kind of complicated but it's
okay we all figure it out when we need
to so spend an afternoon googling like
what is a 401k
and i'll tell you like you'll be glad
that you did that's one of those things
that if you do earlier on and you like
contribute to your 401k
as early as possible you really will get
to reap the rewards later on
and when you get like really confused or
overwhelmed by any of these kind of like
odulty things
remember it's okay to ask for help
the first couple of years in any new
phase of life in my opinion
is all about growing and learning
technically you're never gonna like
stop growing and learning but i think
like in the early years of like
post-grad
is when it's like the most intense
because you're just building your own
foundation
for how to do this and because
everything's new it's gonna be a little
overwhelming but that's okay too
so there's probably gonna be times where
you're like i don't know what i'm doing
but it's okay
you're not supposed to like a lot of
people don't know what they're doing
especially when they're starting out
you've probably heard a lot of people
say that because
it's true like it's true so really
and it took me like a really long time
to realize this
ask for help when you need it like
people like to help
other people like people love to explain
things that they're interested in or
they know well
and like you get to benefit because you
get to learn from their life experiences
and don't worry too much about like if
you're bothering someone if you are then
they'll tell you so like
don't worry too much and just like go
for it in fact if you're in like a field
or workplace where you have a manager
specifically assigned to you
lean on them ask for like weekly
one-on-ones and follow-ups and check-ins
as much as you want to
or maybe a little more than you think
you need to sharing with someone else
that you need help
does require a bit of vulnerability and
i know sometimes it can be scary because
it can feel like a sign of weakness but
in reality
i think it's like one of the strongest
things that you can do
telling someone your worries can
actually help to deepen the relationship
you have with them because it's a great
opportunity for you
and another person to really get to know
each other
and develop a shared experience so
remember you're not alone in all of this
life
is not meant to be done alone and there
are plenty of people who can help you
out in tough times
if you ask for it and this help is
actually so important
because during this time more than
anything
the subject that you're going to be
learning the most about
is yourself right now is the time to
learn who you really
are so when you're going through this
like big huge change
you're probably gonna feel like all this
like adulting and like realness
is like getting thrown at you and again
it's gonna be kind of overwhelming
and it'll feel like a lot of things are
happening very fast and to be fair
it is but given that you get to design
your own life
and you get to put your energy where you
want to and that you can lean on others
for help
this entire process really is here to
help you learn who you really
are and what kind of life you want to
live through all the trial and error
and like the mistakes and like trying to
get out of your comfort zone thing
like you'll realize what's for you and
not for you there'll also probably be
things that you're like
this is not for me right now but maybe
it'll be for me a few years from now
these are all such important cues to
listen and look out for
because that's going to help inform you
where you want to steer your ship
so i think it's really important during
this time to make sure
you're reflecting every so often on your
own feelings and experiences
maybe you'll set up a journaling
practice to write your own thoughts and
feelings
or a thought will randomly cross your
mind while you're commuting to work
whatever the method you'll get to know
yourself really well during this process
doing this work will actually make it a
lot easier to
deal with the ups and downs of work and
then also make big life decisions when
they happen
and you know what self-discovery process
can take a long time
it's normal to feel pressure to figure
out yourself overnight to like know what
you like and don't like and what you
want your career and life to be like but
you don't have to so it's totally okay
if you don't have that figured out just
yet
in fact it's normal if you don't like i
mean i'm i'm still
figuring out myself if i'm honest like i
just remember i felt like i needed to
have like a view or like an opinion on
everything right after graduation
but you don't have to like there's
enough things in our life right now that
like create anxiety
that we don't have to add this huge like
existential thing to our list if we
don't have to
remember how much time you really have
like you have a lot longer than four
years
so you've probably noticed a trend in
all these pieces of advice
that's because it honestly all boils
down to one thing
in this moment you've started your
journey and becoming
more you than you've ever been before
whether it's like the people that you
hang out with
or the area you live or the food you
cook or the type of career you have
you're in the driver's seat that is a
seriously powerful thing
and you'll soon realize adulthood is the
best
so have fun figuring it all out because
you know what
it'll all be okay thank you so much for
watching to the very end and i hope you
liked this video so i believe that one
of the most underrated tenets of
adulting is to continuing to learn
even after graduation and one of the
best resources i've found to help you do
that is
brilliant who is the sponsor of today's
video so you've
heard me talk about brilliant like all
the time like they sponsor
a lot of my videos and i've told you a
lot about what their platform
is and what they do in case you didn't
know brilliant is a website and app
built off the principle of active
problem solving
you learn best while doing and solving
in real time
so jump right into solving problems and
be coached bit by bit
until before you even realize it you've
learned a new subject in stem
so brilliant has actually upped their
interactivity level on their platform to
a whole new level
take this lesson about like the
pythagorean theorem for example
you might remember from school what the
formula is but in this lesson
you're moving around triangles and
actually proving
that a squared plus b squared is equal
to c
squared it's pretty cool stuff and i
think i would have understood like all
of my stem classes much better if there
were stuff like this
and you know what there's more that came
from so if you'd like to join me
and a community of 8 million learners
and educators today
click the link in the description box
down below or visit brilliant.org
hellomyuco alright everybody thanks
again and i'll see you next time
bye